Jonas Jonas
you
Jonas are you all right shout if you're
like bleeding or something
why would a guy bring an ashtray down
here or a pen
see a man about a dog sure will do are
you okay Jesus you scared me what are
you even doing I'm sorry for going ahead
I thought I thought I heard somebody
down here but you know obviously there
isn't but isn't this place incredible I
mean I don't even know how this how this
happens it's honestly creeping me out I
feel like we're in Satan's underground
lair it's a little creepy but I mean
it's all just a cave just a natural cave
see that's what I heard it sounds like a
person almost right kinda I don't know
where it's coming from it what could
that be echoes sounds of the ocean
bouncing off the walls it's me I failed
geology there was a light in here
somewhere like what is this made out of
is it ice I don't know pockets of it are
cold but not all of it there was a look
what wow how is that did you see the
floating um triangle right thing
no where it's like in the the air right
there it must be like a like a rainbow
or like a reflection of light those um
exist right it doesn't really look like
it saw the man not the dog what the crap
does that mean a guy who can't see dogs
did you see the first time see a man
about a dog yeah I don't get it either I
think this is all tied to when you tuned
in apart from the UM triangle this is
honestly the craziest thing in here like
how did I even get in and I mean aside
from some water damage it's not really
even that junkie I know try your radio
maybe that's like a frequency or
something like if it'll have an effect
yeah good idea maybe it'll dancer
twitcher something
let's do it come on radio time oh my god
is this are you is this you are you
doing this how do you think
I can't even like what is what
is it it what
what hello this is insane uh who are you
who are you on that listen I I I don't
know what you mean so I can't [ __ ] me
Alex
Alex Alex
Alex are you okay you all right what
happened that is a very good question
look I'm just gonna cut to the whatever
like I don't know exactly what happened
back there but the sign says that's an
old communications tower and I don't
know about you but I want to climb that
ladder call somebody and get the hell
back home as fast as possible I don't
want to be the party pooper here no I'm
Way ahead of you there's got to be some
kind of emergency station or way to get
out without taking the ferry oh and not
for nothing I'm fine with a little D
pantsing or whatever if the weathers
right for it but if this is some sort of
prank or trick i hardened tower oh it's
called that I think because the radio
man who watched it he was major Richard
harden I don't know why I remember that
what the guy's name was major dick
harden yep it almost makes the whole
trip worth it doesn't it I wouldn't go
that far
I can see the cave but not run or
anybody what do you think happened to
them they're just being lame I can hear
in now let's go to the fort and throw
rocks up walls great hmm the cleaning
guy should probably lock this before he
leaves his stupidity is our gain
how does this thing Spence should be off
now great but um don't take offense if I
want to throw a stick at it first well I
will and have taken offense at your not
believing in my ability at flipping
switches
is um is anyone there
it's um dead did you get any one I don't
think so
warning do not use a board ship unsafe
radiation limits you know I'd normally
find this stuff kind of interesting
really you know normally yeah well I'm
glad you find this sort of thing
interesting because I find it
interminable you find it terminal
interminable inter it means boring Oh
there's a dial tone but there's a note
here
does not call out please dial station
code for service it wouldn't happen to
be a code there with their
nada
ah Jesus oh man whoever you are we
really need your help over here Alex
Nolan oh Jesus hopping Krait thank
Vishnu I you guys wouldn't into that
hole and a bunch of stuff I have no idea
what happened i just woke up like 15
minutes ago I I saw the light on in the
tower thing hey did you know that it's
named after some guy named dick harden
it's me how are you calling us phones
don't work here it's a code written on
this list here but it's not a normal
phone I can't call out I'm at the weigh
station or whatever in the woods it's
been like like just the worst thing ever
Jen are you all right like physically
all right cuz I know mentally no I'm not
all right I mean do I sound all right or
do I sound not all right I probably
sound not all right right wait I think
that's the other line maybe it's like a
night watchman or something Bren
someone's calling on the other line just
hold on a minute I'm gonna see who it is
ok but make it quick seriously
hello oh Jesus Christ Alex why are you
answering it this it says it's an
emergency line where are you right now
Clarissa and Jonas is with you oh my
more calm tower corsa where are you i I
don't know I'm somewhere in Fort Milner
I don't know why I don't remember like
the last hour I'm trying to call
somebody but I'm in a room with radio
stuff that can it says it can contact
kamina but i don't i have no idea how to
make it work can you just come over here
and figure this out with me I don't care
if you guys wanted a I just come here
instead fort Milner's all the way on the
other side of the island yeah i know it
is Alex but why would I go to the comm
tower when there's a working radio that
we can use to get help here fort Milner
looked huge on the map do you know where
that
and it dies li Ren are you still there
yeah I guess that'd be too easy I mean
Clarissa can be a handful but run
sounded kind of more out of sorts than
usual I don't know look I'm gonna leave
it up to you we can swing through the
forest in a Bren or we can go to the
fort and see what Clarissa is up to
they're your people you can decide right
need this more and he'd kill me if he
knew we went to see Clarissa first sound
logic all right our rescuing duties have
officially commenced to get this done
and get off this rock like the badasses
we are